This is the equation in vertex form, and the vertex is at 2, 1. Good thinking
if you found these two. Now, this one was pretty tough, especially since we had
a negative 3 here. Let's work through it together. Our goal is to get a perfect
square so that way we can put this equation in vertex form. So we're going to
try and complete the square by adding some amount to our polynomial. I can't
quite complete the square yet, since I have a factor of negative 3 in front of
the x squared. We want this coefficient to be a one. This means that we can
factor a negative 3 from these two terms, leaving us with negative 3 times x
squared minus 4x. We can quickly check to make sure that if we distribute, we
would get back with what we started with. We'd have a negative 3x squared here
and negative 3 times negative 4x which is positive 12x. Now we're ready to
complete the square. The b term is negative 4, so b divided by 2 equals
negative 2. And b divided by 2 squared equals 4. We simply square this number.
So, we need to add 4 in order to complete the square for this trinomial. But we
didn't just add 4 here, we really added negative 12, 4 times negative 3. Again,
think about the, shooting this negative 3 to each of the three terms, and we
would wind up with this expression. Now we can't just go adding numbers to
equations and changing them at random. Instead we need to keep things balanced.
If we subtract 12 from an equation then that means we need to add 12 to the
equation as well. This makes the equation balance. It makes it so that way it's
not changed. We know this since that negative 12 and positive 12 sum to 0. So
we're just changing what this equation looks like, but it's really the same
exact equation. Now that we're here we're ready to write our perfect square.
The perfect square for this trinomial is x negative 2. If we square this
amount, we'll get this expression. Our negative 3 stays in front as the
coefficient, and then we have negative 11 plus 12 on the end. If we combine the
like terms on the end, we get a positive 1 here. This gives us our equation in
vertex form. And finally, for the vertex, we have an h value of positive 2. And
a k value of positive 1. Setting the binomial equal to 0 gives us the x
coordinate of our vertex. And the k value, or the y coordinate of our vertex,
is just positive 1.